We.
Uh, back in the nineties, the countries of Southeast Asia,
along with South Korea seem to be taking all the world.
They are the next candidates to join the list of the great economic success
stories, banks, investment funds, pension funds,
insurance companies all want to invest in this part of the world.
South Korea and Southeast Asia have become some of the great jewels in the
financial world. However, on the 2nd of July, 1997,
everything fell apart on that day.
One of the greatest financial cataclysms in human history suddenly began to
unfold in just a few months.
The whole world was going to see how these ones booming and prosperous economies
were about to sink into the ocean.
Yeah.
The fact is that within just a year of the crisis,
breaking out the damage had exceeded all reasonable expectations.
The depreciation of local currencies surpassed 35% in all cases,
in the case of the Indonesia and repair, it was a staggering 83%.
And we're not just talking about currencies.
The same thing happened with the stock markets, the stock markets in Indonesia,
South Korea and Thailand recorded falls over 50%.
And take note.
In case you didn't catch what that meant. Let me illustrate that in another way.
This means that a dollar denominated investment in stock markets of these
countries would have recorded a loss of between 60 and 93% in just one
year. For example,
$1,000 invested in the South Korean stock market in June,
1997 would have diminished to a 290 position in just 12.
But we're not just talking about the world of finance.
The economies of these countries suffered considerable damage,
suddenly rising unemployment bank failures and business closures became daily
news events. In one year, the economy of South Korea registered a fall of 5.8%,
that of Thailand 10%. And that of Indonesia, a little more than 13%.
It was the greater Asian financial crisis of 1996.
What happened that caused such trending economies of the day to suddenly
collapsed like a house of cards. What were the causes of the Savage crisis?
These are the questions we will try to answer in this new video,
but we have prepared in collaboration with value school, listen.
Up the.
Asian economic miracle,
July, 1997.
Any analyst had predicted the economic cataclysm that was going to occur during
the following months. It is possible that he or she would have lost their job.
No one, absolutely no one would have taken such a prediction. Seriously,
just one month before the outbreak of the crisis,
the average forecast for economic growth in the region was around 7%.
This was in line with the performance of these economies. In previous years,
at the beginning of 1997,
everything seemed to be in order South Korea and the Southeast Asian countries
had their public accounts. In order,
they had maintained very high levels of economic growth for years.
Inflation was under control and their savings and investment rates were very
high.
Nothing.
Indicated what was to come on. The contrary, the prospects were good. Very good.
So as you can imagine, investment banks funds, hedge funds, commercial banks,
all the players in the financial world wanted a piece of this kind of equity.
[Inaudible].
The inflows of capital that is funds money that's were registered every year
were enormous, which in turn fueled the feeling of prosperity.
The stock markets were rising.
The price of real estate assets just kept growing.
There was money for all kinds of projects and best of all,
with healthy public accounts and an insatiable appetite for investing everything
pointed to the prospect of continued prosperity for the foreseeable future.
Of course,
it was clear that no one could expect such a crisis in countries where even the
governments themselves had fiscal surpluses. However,
we now know that the model had cracks and that that's what we are on a mission
to investigate. What were these cracks?
What happened to make everything fall apart overnight? Well,
the time has come to get to work and examine all of those weak links.
The cracks that caused the collapse,
okay.
You've already described it in the 1990s,
South Korea and Southeast Asia were enjoying a financial golden era. However,
little by little, some imbalances had developed,
which were not considered important, but that oversight would end up costing.
You see.
In the early 1990s,
the United States went through a mild economic crisis that ended with the 1991
recession.
This caused the us federal reserve to lower interest rates to well below the
rates that existed in South Korea and Southeast Asian countries.
And this together with the high rates of economic growth that these countries
had been registering is what caused international capital to begin flooding into
this region of the world capital that was added to the very high savings
reserves that these economies already had. In other words,
we are talking about a series of events that suddenly provided money for
everything. There,
there is the point of when the problems began on the one hand,
the price of assets shot up one on the other hand investments in all kinds of
projects, multiplied export industry, which by the way,
was favored by the governments themselves created a huge overcapacity and many
of the real estate and public works projects were barely used when they were
finished. In other words,
a lot of capital was being invested in projects whose profitability was more
than questionable. And so bubble was created. And of course,
when the United States began to recover and Alan Greenspan's federal reserve
began to raise interests, the attractiveness of these markets began to decline,
but that's that, wasn't the only problem that they had to worry about.
The rise.
First in the United States led to an appreciation of the dollar and therefore of
the currencies of those countries,
which were patched to the U S currency by a fixed exchange rate.
That in itself was one of the great attractions those countries had for foreign
investors. However,
this appreciation of the currencies with respect to other major currencies,
such as the yen or the Mark caused these Asian countries to lose
competitiveness, to make matters worse in 1994,
China had carried out a devaluation of the UN more than 30 years
As a result export growth began to slow down for Southeast Asia and South Korea.
In 1996, this had two consequences. On the one hand,
it increased the overcapacity of the export sector further reducing the
profitability and even the viability of the investments made.
And on the other hand,
given the massive influx of capital of cash that continued to arrive the loss of
export momentum meant that the current account balance that is the difference
between income and the payments to the rest of the world would register
considerably large deficit.
Levels. The fact.
Is that the accumulation of current account deficits it's been financed by
foreign debt. So to give you an idea in 1996,
the foreign debt of these countries exceeded 165% of their gross domestic
product faced with such a scenario.
Only one turning point was needed a minor interruption to turn the whole system
upside down. And that's just what happened on the 2nd of July, 1990.
Thailand, the turning point.
1993 In that year,
taking advantage of the enormous influx of capital that was flooding Southeast
Asia.
The Thai government decided to create an entire international financial center
in Bangkok with the intention of competing with Singapore and Hong Kong to
achieve this, the Thai government did what it is usually done in such cases.
It ease regulations on the capital market,
introduced tax incentives and promoted the creation of a whole financial
industry.
And the truth is that things began to go in the right direction soon and was
specializing in foreign exchange lending operations that is borrowing capital
nominated in major international currencies,
such as the dollar and channeling it into all types of investment projects in
local currency. In this way,
Bangkok became one of the great gateways to the economies of Southeast Asia.
What happened is that his experience as a financial center was very limited and
the regulations, well, let's just say they were pretty ineffective.
But.
Do you remember what else was happening?
The enormous influx of capital into this part of the world meant that large
amounts of resources were invested in projects that would never be profitable
resources. That's don't forget,
came from loans that there was little hope of paying back.
And that is precisely what led to a growing deterioration in the credit
portfolios of Thai financial institutions, or in other words,
a whole lot more default,
take a look according to estimates made after the crisis by the international
monetary fund loans in an erratic situation that is,
that began to have problems being repaid or paying interest reached levels of
between 15 and 24%. However,
despite the fact that these were figures that could make any analyst hair stand
on end, none of this appeared in the bank's annual accounts,
lacks financial rules and lack of experience and supervision meant that loans in
irregular situations were refinanced without being classified as dubious.
And not only that interest that had never actually been received was also
usually accounted for and many companies in trouble were lent even more money to
pay off interest. They already owed on previous loans. That's just crazy.
[Inaudible].
Is that with these techniques,
profits were plumped up allowing financial institutions to distribute dividends,
give out huge bonuses and pay taxes, but all financed with more and more debt.
It was a crazy race to collapse that continued until it was simply too late
because of the tiny financial institutions finally ran out of money and began to
have trouble meeting their international creditors.
Remember that they had specialized in raising capital from the rest of it.
The world.
The situation became so critical that between the months of March and June,
1997,
the central bank of Thailand secretly had to provide liquidity to the country's
financial institutions at bargain interest rates using its international
reserves.
The problem was that these reserves began to be consumed very quickly and
there's the situation of the banks continue to worsen. On the 2nd of July,
the Thai government was forced to announce the end of the fixed parity of its
currency. The bot would no longer be pegged to the U S dollar.
They no longer had anything to back up a currency that began to suffer enormous
stress in the face of the capital flight that was beginning to take.
As you can.
And imagine the end of the association with the dollar resulted in a huge
collapse of the bot,
which far from improving the situation of the banks only aggravated it. Why?
Well, because the banks had taken out loans in dollars.
That is its liabilities were denominated in dollars and its assets in local
currency.
They owed dollars and had nothing to pay the back with in July in 1997,
the IMF estimated that the whole amounted to at least 9% of Thailand's GDP,
an overwhelming majority of the financial entities were bankrupt.
And according to the IMF own technicians,
only the biggest banks would manage to stay afloat,
suddenly international depositors and investors saw the writing on the wall,
not only in Thailand,
but also in all countries of the region that shared the same economic
characteristics,
foreign lines of credit dried up and capital flight drags down the entire
financial systems of these countries. The contagion effect was total.
[Inaudible].
In 1996, Indonesia, South Korea, Malaysia,
the Philippines and Thailand had received $66 billion from abroad in net terms
in 97, they received just $36 billion.
The variation amounted to $112 billion,
12% of the combined GDP of these nations at the time,
the crisis was first felt in Thailand, but in less than two months,
it turned into a full blown Asian crisis in just one month,
the South Korean one sank from 1000 to 2001 on the dollar in just
one month, just a few weeks after the outbreak of the crisis in Thailand,
the forecast for economic growth in these countries changed abruptly.
Hello
in this is the story.
Of the 1997 Asian crisis. One of the biggest financial crises in history,
a crisis that forced the Asian countries involved to carry out enormous
restructuring and to receive bailouts of $120 billion.
Despite this only South Korea managed to recover in a reasonably short amount of
time, we are talking about a crisis that had a lot of consequences for about the
financial world consequences,
which we will surely talk about here on visual politics in collaboration with
value school. So I really hope you enjoyed this video.
Please hit like if you did, and don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos.
Don't forget to check out our friends at the reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals in the episode that were not mine.
And also the channel is possible because of Patrion.
And there were patrons on the platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you in the next video.
And if you want to learn more about politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice, you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsidermedia.com slash podcast. See you there.